aber jetzt kommen wir erstmal zur These
von Antje Hermenau und die ist nämlich
eigentlich ganz verbunden mit meiner
These denn da geht es um den Standort
made in Germany ja und der ist jetzt
echt in Gefahr also es gab vielleicht
ein paar frühe Warner die waren ein
bisschen zu straff in ihren Aussagen
aber jetzt haben wir wirklich das
Problem vor der Haustür liegen ähm wir
sehen das an den großen Firmen an dem
Monopolen die sagen wir gehen aus
Deutschland weg es gibt keine
langfristigen Investitionen in
Deutschland mehr wenn jetzt ein paar
fratcher vom
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut sagt na ja
fünf bis sechs Jahre mindestens wird so
hohe Energiepreise geben und wir kommen
nicht klar und vielleicht müssen wir ja
dann auch lastenabwurf machen also
abschalten dann sagen sich die großen
die da auch immer Rede und Antwort
stehen müssen vor den ganzen Leuten die
anteilseigenen Firmen sind dann können
wir in Europa und in Deutschland nicht
mehr investieren wir haben da glaube ich
ein großes Problem vor der Haustür das
ist also die Energie Frage die dazu
führt dass er Energie das Firmen hier
weggehen also nicht nur jetzt die großen
aber chemische Industrie Baustoffe
vielleicht auch Stahl und Aluminium
schmelzen und das sind ganz viele
Vorprodukte drin Papierholz ganz viele
Vorprodukte die wir alle brauchen damit
wir die schönen Produkte machen die wir
immer noch weltweit halbwegs verkaufen
können aber die Energiepreise machen es
jetzt so das ganze Branchen ausgedünnt
werden dann gehen dort Arbeitsplätze
verloren und zwar von qualifizierten
Facharbeitern die auch hohe Steuern
bezahlen wohin die dann gehen werden wir
sehen manche haben bestimmt eine Chance
bei dem Fachkräftemangel den wir haben
woanders unterzukommen und wir werden
sehen es werden auch Arbeitsplätze im
niedrig bezahlten Sektor wegfallen weil
durch die Digitalisierung einiges
geändert wird muss auch mal langsam
werden mit der Digitalisierung wir
hatten es gerade aber das sind dann
wieder andere Arbeitsplätze die
betroffen sind so oder so kommt mir das
vor wie es damals Anfang der 90er Jahre
in Ostdeutschland gewesen ist als wir
auf einmal auf einer ganzen Industrie
gesessen haben die nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig war innerhalb weniger
Monate und Jahre war da alle im
Kahlschlag es gab dann sehr viele
Arbeitslosen die wurden aufgefangen in
irgendwelchen Beschäftigungsmaßnahmen
der Bundesagentur für Arbeit wir hatten
dann sehr viele westliche Firmen die
haben dann bei uns eine wie wir das
nennen verlängerte Werkbank aufgebaut
also eine Produktionsstätte dann haben
wir da ordentlich fleißig gearbeitet und
sobald ein bisschen Krise war oder das
Ding zugemacht und da war im Osten
wieder keine Firma da ähm das ist eine
ganz gefährliche Tendenz diese Regierung
war nachlässigt übersieht den
Mittelstand der Mittelstand ist das Herz
in diesem Land und hat ja immer dazu
beigetragen einen großen sozialen
Frieden im Land zu haben weil wir eben
eine breite Mittelschicht hatten und die
bröckelt jetzt von unten weg und oben
auch und das wird glaube ich zu
Verwerfung führen es kann sein dass es
noch einmal welchen dauert aber meiner
Meinung nach werden wir schleichend in
einem Prozess hinein münden der dazu
führt dass wir Teil die
industrialisieren und ich kann Ihnen
sagen als ein Mensch der eine die
Industrialisierung schon einmal
mitgemacht hat das ist für die Menschen
furchtbar wer sind ihre Prognosen hier
nicht zu schwarz man kann ja
beispielsweise die Energiepreise die
sind ja schon auch wieder gesund
geworden
also das ist jetzt nur weil der minder
wild verlaufen ist weil die Strahlen und
alle guten z.B alle nicht produziert
haben deswegen weniger Gas verbraucht
das teure Gras ist immer noch in den
speichern dass das täuscht wir werden ja
weiter abschalten wir werden der
Kapazitäten für die Stromerzeugung
weiter abschalten so ist die Planung man
schaltet jetzt im Frühjahr die
Atomkraftwerke ab ich gebe ihnen völlig
recht das ist dumm dann haben wir die
Situation dass die dass die Braunkohle
wieder zurückgefahren werden soll dann
ist nicht ganz klar wie viel Grad sind
wirklich importieren können jetzt im
Moment ist es sehr billig das kann sich
wieder ändern wir haben mehrere Jahre
vor uns und das sagen ganz inzwischen
auch Leute wie Herr Fratzscher diese
chef-ideologen dieser Art von
Wirtschaftsform das war fünf sechs Jahre
vor uns liegen wo es nicht zuverlässig
Strom gibt die glauben doch nicht dass
in die Wirtschaft dann hier investiert
das ist absurd also die Frage was
mittelfristig passiert also dieses
langsame nach unten gleiten ne das ist
eine entscheidende Frage für diesen
Standort und dann haben wir ja noch das
demografische Problem sozusagen dass wir
auch den jungen Leuten die hier arbeiten
gar nicht aufbürden können noch die
ganzen Probleme der Rentenversicherung
mitzuschlagen und mitzutragen wir werden
die Steuerfinanzierung kommen und die
Steuern hier die kriegen wir eigentlich
über die Wirtschaft ich sage mal wer ist
nicht schafft die Marktwirtschaft zu
halten der hat dann auch keinen soziales
mehr eine soziale Marktwirtschaft sind
zwei Seiten einer Münze und wir
riskieren gerade alles
das sind düstere Prognosen die Frau
Hermenau hier aufzeichnet was können wir
denn tun um den Standort Deutschland zu
behalten als gut ich finde gar nicht
düster ich finde die extrem realistisch
und sie haben sich nichts ausgedacht sie
haben nur kurz und sehr gut den ist
Zustande referiert haben sie wir leben
so wirklich in einer Art von Tagtraum
und die Grünen sind autoritäre
Romantiker die haben eine Vorstellung
von der Gesellschaft diese durchsetzen
wollen ja aber leider gegen alle
Naturgesetze gerichtet ist wenn ich
diesen Federhalter fallen lasse dann
fällt nach unten der fällt nicht nach
oben aber die Grünen relativieren alles
die gender Debatte spricht dafür es wird
überall entgrenzt jeder kann was er
möchte es wird nicht klappen ich sehe in
Deutschland genauso leider das tut mir
auch weh im Untergang oder vielleicht
ist sie Niedergang wie Sie wissen Sie
ein Land in dem so viel Aufmerksamkeit
für eine hysterische Truppe wie die
letzte Generation aufgewendet
wird dieses Land hat sich schon selbst
aufgegeben die letzte Generation vor
kurzem in der Nähe des Frankfurter
Flughafens auf eine viel befahrenen
Autobahn eine Aktion gestartet müssen
sich vorstellen Zufalls und Frankfurter
Flughafen tausende von Leuten lassen
ihren Auto fest und dann sollten sich
diese Idealisten dieser faschistoiden
Idealisten Seiten sich dann von der
Brücke ab um den Verkehr zu stoppen und
jetzt kommt die Bayern unter die Polizei
hatte diese Aktion genehmigt wenn das
der Begriff von Rechtsstaaten von
Demokratie ist dann ist das zeigt die
Glocken zu Leuten aber wenn wir noch mal
auf die Wirtschaft blicken jetzt weg von
den klimaaktivisten wie können wir die
Wirtschaft wieder ankurbeln
ich weiß es nicht ich bin kein Ökonomen
und ich danke dem Herrn dass ich kein
Ökonom bin aber ich werde jeden Tag
getröstet aber sie haben Semester
Wirtschaft studiert ja aber ich habe es
nicht wegen der Wirtschaft gemacht dann
gab es andere Motive nein wenn ich
wissen Sie wir haben doch die
Wirtschaftsweisen wir haben ja auf der
einen Seite Herrn Sinn und Herrn Flasche
auf der anderen Seite der komischerweise
auch bei den Inflation immer das sagt
was der Regierung gerade verkündet nicht
wahr die sind da irgendwie und immer
falsch
nein nein nein ja ja er hat nämlich
wissen wer hat das alte Artisten Prinzip
adaptiert mache ich einen Fehler auf der
Bühne mache ich gleich einen zweiten
hinterher dann sitzt nach Methode
Aussicht und keiner mehr das ist ein
Fehler war ich weiß nicht was wir tun
können ich fürchte der point of Naruto
nicht sagte schon ist überschritten und
sie können eine Lawine die
heruntergeräumt ist und ein halbesdorf
abgeräumt hat nicht höflich bitten
wieder den Berg aufzuräumen das
funktioniert nicht und diese Situation
sind wir jetzt dieses Land beschäftigt
mit Bagatellen wirklich dieses Land über
sich vorstellen 1% der Weltbevölkerung
die
Prozent der CO2-Emissionen hervorbringen
will weltweit der Spitzenreiter bei der
Klimarettung sein wissen Sie ich kann
nicht schwimmen aber vielleicht könnte
ich in Deutschland Lebensrettung
Gesellschaft übernehmen und dann sind
sofort die Boote auf Elektroantrieb
umstellen wir Fragen hier einmal Herrn
Platz befindet sich Deutschland in der
selbstbeschäftigungsfalle wenn man das
hört die Debatten sind anscheinend nicht
die die geführt werden müssen definitiv
also zum Thema letzte Generation oder
letzte Degeneration wie es gerne nennen
würde ein selbstverständlich das sind
Debatten die braucht kein Mensch und
deswegen ist das Thema von ihnen finde
ich so wichtig denn wenn man sich
anschaut jeden Monat ich schau mal das
jeden Monat dieses Drama an diese
Arbeitslosenzahlen die falsch sind das
ist völlig klar diesen schönen gerechnet
weiß jeder aber interessiert auch keinen
irgendwie nicht mehr jeden Monat
anschauen und im letzten Jahr
wir hatten noch nie so viel
Beschäftigung wie heute ja das ist die
eine Seite damit Medaille aber
Kurzarbeit geht seit Jahren immer wieder
nach oben das ist das erste das zweite
ist reden wir von Bullshit Jobs reden
wir von Unternehmen die man zombietern
den prekären Arbeitsverhältnisse steigen
steigen die Verhältnisse steigen
einerseits ja aber die Frage ist zu
welchem Preis wenn Sie ein Unternehmen
haben das nur aufgrund von niedriger
Zinsen am Leben gehalten wird oder sogar
durch direkte isolventionen das sind das
eigentlich keine Jobs die da sind die
sind nicht da die werden halt nur
einfach geschaffen wie man früher in DDR
einfach Jobs geschaffen hat die gar
keine Jobs waren und das ist ein Problem
aber sie würden doch schon auch sagen es
gab ja noch nie so viel offenen Jobs
also da muss man ja nicht nur da muss
man übrigens nicht nur den Statistiken
glauben man muss nur einmal durch die
Stadt laufen wie Berlin ich habe noch
nie so viel Job Aushängeschilder gesehen
definitiv das ist die andere Seite dann
kann man sich zwei Fragen stellen
erstmal welche Jobs einerseits natürlich
Fachkräfte ohne Ende gerade auch im
älteren Segmente der Herren und Damen
als ab 45 das ist völlig vorbei das wie
früher dass die Leute nicht mehr
gebraucht werden im Gegenteil gerade im
Bereich Senior also Logistik aber auch
viele mehr die Leute werden gesucht aber
sie gibt es halt nicht wo sind ja
entweder sind sie in Jobs die
tatsächlich ja subventioniert werden
oder eben
wenn Sie sich anschauen und
durchschnittliches Unternehmen die die
Deutsche Bahn bekommen noch mal drauf ja
das wird im subventioniert und die Leute
bleiben dort die bleiben bei diesen Jobs
weil sie gerade wenn sie älter sind sie
haben Angst auf dem Jobwechsel aber
manchmal merken sie gar nicht die
älteren gut qualifizierten dass sie
wirklich gebraucht werden und noch mehr
nach oben gehen die andere Seite wird
alles natürlich im Helfer Jobs da gebe
ich Ihnen Recht die tatsächlich werden
auch gesucht aber im Wesentlichen
weniger und die Leute finden sie finden
auch nicht mehr Helfer mehr das ist das
Problem die finden noch nicht mal die
einfachsten Jobs im im
lagerhelferbereich Lebensmittelhandwerk
sie finden diese Leute nicht mehr und
die sind doch jenseits vom Mindestlohn
ist die werden auch mehr bezahlt egal
Leute
haben die Leute keine Anreize mehr zum
arbeiten
ja ich will hier die ganze Debatte die
wir hier noch ein bisschen relativieren
weil da wird schon gesprochen über
dieses Land und so weiter also so eine
Art deutschland schafft sich ab
Atmosphäre also ich habe natürlich nach
wie vor viel Kontakt zu den Niederlanden
verfolgt auch die Nachrichten da und da
sind die Debatten und die Probleme sehr
sehr ähnlich also wenn wir schauen über
ein Problem reden dann reden wir hier
über ein größeres West europäisches oder
vielleicht sogar zum Teil in westliches
Problem
wenn ich Beispiel letzte Generation die
haben natürlich in der Niederlanden auch
und den in der Niederlande gab es sogar
ein Skandal in der letzten Woche also in
einem mit öffentlichen Steuermitteln von
finanzierten debattierzentrum in
Amsterdam diskutiert werden sollte mit
Beteiligung von einem
Parlamentsmitglied der Grünen Partei
auch über die Frage ob es nicht Zeit sei
jetzt Gewalt anzuwenden weil ja sonst
geht die Welt unter
zum Glück war die Reaktion dann so dass
dieses Parlament gezogen war abzusagen
die ganze Veranstaltung abgesagt wurde
ob es zeigt wie weit das auch in den
Niederlanden geht oder im Bereich wenn
wir über Stillstand reden
es wird den Holland schon seit
anderthalb Jahren keine Wohnung mehr
gebaut weil wir gegen irgendwelche
stickstoffregel der Europäischen Union
verstoßen was wieder damit zu tun hat
dass wir tausende von klitzekleine
Natura 2000 Gebiete
angegemeldet haben bei der EU und um
diesen Gebieten herum darf man dann kein
Stickstoff
also
Bauernbetriebe müssen zu machen es kann
nicht mehr gebaut werden es können keine
Regel mehr gebaut werden also zum Teil
ist also es gibt Bereiche was schlimmer
ist in Deutschland gibt Bereiche aber
schlimmer ist in der Niederlande aber es
ist kein spezifisch deutsches Europa
schafft sich ab
naja die besten die westliche Welt hat
natürlich ist sie viel zu viel mit sich
selbst beschäftigt viel zu viel mit der
selbstlamentierung mit einer
selbstständig beschäftigungsphase ich
glaube schon dass wir durch den Ukraine
kriegt da anwenden eine Wende
hingekriegt habe in dem Sinne bin ich
weniger pessimistisch aus vielleicht die
anderen Tisch im Deutschen haben die
höchsten Strompreise insgesamt also da
war schon vor dem Ukraine Krieg doppelt
so hoch wie in anderen Konkurrenzländern
und er ist jetzt vervierfacht und wir
werden diese Konkurrenz eben nicht mehr
aushalten wir die Chinesen doch die
amerikanische ich bin sehr dafür wir
müssen unbedingt alles anschmeißen was
Energie produziert und die Energiepreise
senken das ist das A und O das wieder
Blutkreislauf im Körper ich weiß nur ein
Satz zu ihnen sie haben vollkommen recht
es ist die Zustände in denen wir leben
in ein Produkt der
Wohlstandsverwahrlosung ganz allgemein
und dieser beschränkt sich nicht auf
Deutschland aber es gibt einen großen
Unterschied sie haben glaube ich 16
Millionen Bevölkerung 17 inzwischen und
wir haben jetzt 84 und Deutschland gibt
nun mal das Tempo vor Deutschland gibt
den Ton an Holland Gott sei Dank nicht
außer bei der Freigabe von Rauschmittel
das war ihre Domäne und deswegen ist es
schlimmer was hier passiert weil das hat
ein Fluss und das hat Rückwirkungen auf
die gesamte EU klar in einem gebe ich
Ihnen vollkommen recht das Problem ist
nicht Deutschland das Problem ist dieser
wahnsinnige Brüsseler Wasserkopf namens
EU müssen sie haben das wahrscheinlich
schon gemacht Marco gucken womit die
sich beschäftigen welche Verordnungen da
erlassen werden aber auch in Deutschland
ich habe gerade im Radio ein neues Wort
gehört
massenzuwanderungsrichtlinie der Grund
ist es sehr witzig das ist beinahe so
witzig wie klimaanpassungsgesetz nicht
wir sagen dem Klima wie es sich anpassen
soll und deswegen ist es bedeutende was
Deutschland macht weil das hat enorme
Rückwirkungen und Europa kann es nicht
auffangen Europa kann sich auffangen
schauen sie ist dieser Debatte die
durchgefallen sind Europäischen
Parlament über das Verbot von
verbrennermotoren die diskutieren seit
10 Jahren darüber und im letzten Moment
ist es nicht verabschiedet worden weil
sich Deutschland dagegen gestellt hat
genau genommen die CDU-Fraktion Gott sei
Dank wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie